Students in China tie their hair to the ceiling
to prevent themselves falling asleep whilst
studying.
Welcome to RIF
Traces of cocoa and nicotine found in some
Egyptian mummies have let to speculations
that Ancient Egyptians may have traveled to
the new world.
The brain consumes 20% of the body's energy,
yet it only accounts for 2% of our total body
weight.
The engine of the BMW M5 is so quiet the company
plays fake engine noises through the car's
speakers to remind drivers of their cars performance.
One quarter of the bones in your body are
in your feet.
The tip of a bullwhip moves so fast that when
you hear it crack, the sound it makes is actually
a tiny sonic boom.
"Almost" is the longest word in the English
language with all the letters in alphabetical
order.
Human thigh bones are stronger than concrete.
Earth is the only planet in our solar system
not named after a god.
One in Five adults believe that aliens are
hiding on our planet disguised as humans.
And finally, there are no naturally occurring
blue foods, even blueberries are purple!